we've got some breaking news coming out
of Westminster for you Sky News
understands the labor party has received
a second formal complaint against garant
Davis MP you'll remember the labor MP
was suspended from the party pending an
investigation into reports of what were
described as incredibly serious
allegations of completely unacceptable
behavior let's show on our political
correspondent to Liz Bates Liz bring us
up to speed
yes well you remember you can see him
there he is the MP for Swansea West this
all kicked off yesterday uh when a wave
of allegations emerged in the media
after that a formal complaint was put
into the party in a full investigation
was launched what we understand uh this
afternoon is that a second formal
complaint has now gone in against him
that and that investigation continues to
be underway we haven't heard anything
from him since yesterday morning when he
released a statement to Politico saying
he didn't recognize the allegations
um but that if he if he had caused any
offense he was naturally sorry this
comes as well after a pretty explosive
interview today with a back bench labor
MP Charlotte Nichols she's really been
putting pressure on her own party in the
wake of those allegations emerging
against Grant Davis to address what she
says are other outstanding allegations
against sitting labor MPS that she
accuses the party of just simply not
dealing with she particularly talked
about a case involving a shadow cabinet
minister who she says is still currently
in post despite having a complaint put
into the police about him so she's
really been uh putting pressure on her
party today to take action she she says
they're sitting on their hands when it
comes to these complaints the party in a
statement they said this all all day
yesterday and are continuing to say that
if people do have allegations on sexual
misconduct or or bullying or anything in
that area then they need to come forward
and make a formal complaint to the party
at that point they say there will be a
full investigation it will be done by
via an independent process and they'll
be fully supported all the way through
it so that is the current situation with
the labor party as of this evening